hey how's it I'm shaving Woodley and I'm
a New York shape energy cube I grew up
in a small suburb outside of Los Angeles
called Simi Valley and so I got to grow
up hiking and I got to grow up knowing
with the sound of a coyote was that
really catered to my love of like
athleticism nowadays man of the air okay
there's this dude his name is Josh Fox
and he's created two documentaries one
is called Gasland and then he did
another one called Gasland Part two it's
all about fracking
they're so educational and they're so
moving and I just think I think the
world of him so Josh Fox funniest person
of the year miles teller hands on I
think he might be the funniest person of
every year that has ever existed tivity
wise wow that's a tough one I think it'd
be a toss-up between cookie and she
Jitsu I think would actually probably be
the two but it works out good you know
you do your jujitsu you're sweaty you're
starving and you get to eat I am easy
one thing I bucket list I'm gonna check
off next year I've always wanted to ride
my bike through France and that is a
goal for next year one word 2014
powerful and it's the year of the horse
it's fun and it's powerful
[Music]